if you watched early MMA well it was
kind of like whatever you wanted so like
some guys wore geese some guy was wore
wrestling shoes there's this one guy he
was a boxer and he wore one boxing glove
and won their hand you know so like
there's some really like hilarious
things back in the day one of the things
I was hilarious about Pride was that
they not only allowed PDS they
encouraged PDS what do you think the
sport would be better off if people just
were allowed to no you also boxed Jake
Paul only once yeah one time why'd you
do it
um all right guys bang bang I've got Ben
here with me uh you got a fascinating
life and I thought a great way to kind
of understand what the hell you've been
through uh is to start off first talking
about just Excellence like I feel like a
lot of the things that you've done in
your life you've tried to be the best at
it uh talk like what does excellence
mean to you and why has that been such a
focus for you yeah uh I mean and that's
kind of the way I think about things
like if I'm gonna try to do something I
might as well try to be the best at it I
don't really see any reason not to you
know I've never even make a good
argument like why should you just do
something thinking like do it average
but it's also perhaps because I'm very
obsessive about things you know
um so I mean obviously like later in my
life I learned disc golf you know and um
I started playing and I just got
obsessed with it right and I'm like okay
I want to go play a tournament now see
if I'm actually good or not and then I
played in this tournament and I sucked
and I'm like oh wait if I can throw good
but I can't putt worth a damn so it's
like okay I need to go buy a basket and
put in my front yard you know and then
obsessively Putt and I got to the point
where I you know I went on the pro level
I wasn't good but I took second of the
amateur Nationals you know so I was like
really high level at that and so yeah I
just don't see a reason not to do things
really well and maybe it's because I'm
super obsessive and people other people
are like kind of all over the place but
that's just my personality why do you
like disc golf like I've seen the videos
I know you've got funky phone have you
played yet huh I played once or twice
when I was in high school oh okay and
like it was kind of a thing that people
did uh one time and like yeah I've done
it and then they never did it again what
the disc golf actually drink 2020 Corona
disc golf just freaking took off
popularity
because people wanted to be outside and
then they could stay far away from other
people you know so disc golf like kind
of blew up and uh you know there's guys
get million dollar contracts now for
some sponsors on the other basis really
yeah so Paul McBeth got uh you should
head him down here he's uh or your
brother right your brother talks more
Sports uh he's out of Jacksonville now
but he got a million dollar a year
contract from Discraft uh who sponsors
me also uh for me I think you know what
I think it really is is the the
immediate feedback so you take this disc
right and once you get good each one of
them does something a little different
and then you get to Envision the way
it's going to fly and then you rip it
and you get to try to watch it fly the
way you wanted to fly and when you when
you get something good like would you
envision your head it's like oh that was
awesome is it literally golf but with
discs like for the most part it's
there's par there's putting like the
whole thing yes but you're just throwing
rather than yeah I have a really simple
argument for disc golf over golf do you
wanna hear it yeah okay number one golf
takes too damn long I don't know if you
ever played anything golf have you my
brothers and I usually go uh not every
Friday but many Fridays it takes like
five hours yeah it's a all afternoon
activity okay like five hours so disc
golf you know if you got a group
probably hour hour and a half depending
on how difficult the course is not gonna
take super long number two generally in
most places it's free now right there's
it's interesting pay to play but not
it's not that much it's like in parks
and stuff
um number three if you want a disc golf
set generally I would recommend you
start with like say three or four discs
uh that's gonna run you save let's say
60 bucks to 80 bucks somewhere in there
maybe you can get like one golf club for
that right yes and then the last one
someone busy like you uh or like me you
don't need tea times right so you just
show up and play like if you thought hey
you know you thought this podcast is
going to last an hour in the last two
hours well if you miss your tea time
you're screwed right but disc golf you
just call and play that's my arguments
that's actually a pretty strong argument
I think the hard part is just uh people
gotta get good at throwing the disc yeah
uh well I think so I think if you if you
have someone that's relatively
knowledgeable to get like a base level
would be probably easier than golf I I
would think just because um to get
really good now that's going to take a
lot right but to get just understand how
to throw it straight a couple hundred
feet like I If you you're an athlete
right I could take you out the parking
in 20 30 minutes I would have you
throwing it a couple hundred feet
straight relatively straight you know
yeah you could not do that with a golf
club yes golf yeah I golfed for a few
years when I was like really young and
then my parents said hey you got to pay
for it I'm like uh I'm out yeah you know
like you're like seventh grade or eighth
grade and then they're like oh you gotta
pay now I'm like all right I'm done with
that when I want to talk about Combat
Sports in general one of the things
that's fascinating to me is like you had
this illustrious wrestling career yeah
uh but you can't punch people right it's
just straight wrestling is that
frustrating I've always wanted I like
watching wrestling and I'm like if
you're actually mad or competitive or
whatever
in a fight but kind of not in the fight
like how did you think about that or is
it just second nature because you've
just been trained so much that you can't
like that's not a thing yeah yeah I
would say this a little bit second
nature but wrestling is actually funny I
just read this uh the last book
everybody was called meditations by
Marcus Aurelius and it's funny because
wrestling is mentioned so many times
probably six to eight times and so
wrestling is like it's such within the
human condition to like grab someone and
try to manipulate them or take them down
um no I mean when it's okay I started
wrestling there was no MMA right I mean
it literally didn't exist I started
wrestling probably 1991 when I was well
I've been seven years old and the first
very first MMA competition in 1993. wow
you know and then I remember watching
some early ones like my dad got the the
VHS tape and then uh what'd you think uh
I was fascinated I really was I so I
remember like part of me even at I think
I would have been nine or ten years old
definitely felt like oh my God some of
these dudes are so stupid I I actually
talk about the book I have this vivid
memory my dad bought the homeless tape
and it's like hey let's watch this
fighting thing you know because in the
beginning it wasn't like hey this is MMA
it was like hey let's see who where I
mean it's the beginning of me who lets
you wins does a wrestler win does a
Jitsu guy win does a boxer win like what
what wins when all these things happen
you know genius idea it really is
because really everyone I know because
and then you know what we found out was
most uh like taekwondo and karate were
kind of a little bit bullcrap I mean
there's there's some things we can take
but not that much
um so I remember watching it and I I
wish I remembered exactly what UFC it
was I don't probably one two three four
five some something really early you
know and there was this one guy and he
was talking about how tough he was
because he punches this bag of cements
and she was like a block of cement with
some duct tape around the guy was just
you know like sticking it with it and
I'm like oh my god what the hell is
wrong with this guy this is so so
ridiculous like how's he getting good at
Fighting by punching a block of concrete
you know that's like my simple 10 year
old thought
um but I was intrigued by it and then it
kind of went away for a while I mean
you're right you don't remember the
history of MMA but everyone started
Banning it I think by the end it was
only legal in like four states or
something because the first thing they
were promoting the first tagline was uh
eight men enter one man leaves like you
know what this notion that someone's
gonna die right yeah and uh great
marketing for the consumer probably not
so great for the regulators and the
licensing yeah so I think I think
actually only one person's ever died in
30 years of regulated mixed martial arts
and this is all bare knuckle when it
first started it was yeah I mean if you
watched early MMA well it was kind of
like whatever you wanted so like some
guys wore geese some guy was wore
wrestling shoes uh there's this one guy
really famous fight guy named art
Jimerson he was a boxer and he wore one
boxing glove one their hand you know so
like
um you know there's some really like
hilarious things back in the day there's
a sumo wrestler who wore his out you
know it's kind of his outfit
um so you kind of saw a little bit
everything back there back then and then
um yeah so it went away and kind of
because it got banned everywhere you
know when there's no no one would
distribute it and then you know
obviously zuffa buys it in 2002. so if
you're watching MMA so that was kind of
my high school time period it was like
you were really like having to dig deep
to go find some VHS tape somewhere and I
remember we we always enjoyed it because
I think that the wrestlers came in
um maybe like late 90s ish so there's a
guy in like Mark Coleman Kevin Randleman
guys who had high success in wrestling
started doing really well in mixed
martial arts so that was you know like I
said in the beginning it was like which
discipline is better you know every
discipline makes martial arts every
martial art wants to have pride in their
discipline and so when wrestlers started
doing really well I was like oh that's
really awesome but it was still like
this thing that's like yeah over here
when the restaurant started to do well
how much of it was like the wrestlers
were just taking people down and they
didn't know how to like defend against
gonna take them down versus the
wrestlers had gotten good at punching
and kicking and like other uh kind of
components of the club uh I would say
those guys that I mentioned um
you know one thing the wrestlers they
work really hard okay especially I would
say compared to the other martial arts
even currently they still work really
hard right and so they had a ton of
success and they they picked up other
things relatively quickly
um so I'd say those guys kind of were a
little bit good everywhere but yes
obviously uh Mark Coleman
uh and he's still around I just I'm
coaching at uh the most recent UFC he
made the term ground and pound right so
I I remember you know the exact he's I'm
gonna take him to the ground I'm gonna
pound him right so you just take him
down and they just keep punching him and
I I believe for a while head butts were
still legal so one of the things that
grabbed the head and you know they would
they would well because you can cut
people really easily right here with
this part of your head and what it used
to be bare knuckle uh head butting but
also couldn't you kick people when they
were on the ground like uh yeah I was
standing up or something that was in
Pride I don't remember when they banned
that in America but then well the other
one was nut shots were legal for a while
and there's this one famous one of this
dude elbows him in the nuts and it kind
of you know ends the fight
um yeah so it was like really really
limited rule set and then when zoofer
took over I think they were like how do
we work with the regulars that's kind of
like the crypto industry huh yeah yeah
and some people like no way but then
most people realize it's probably going
to be a little bit better when we do
yeah um and and so what they basically
did was they just created clear rules
they put gloves people they like cleaned
it up to a degree but still kept the
Like Gladiator slash like eight you know
two people go in one comes out type
mentality it just was in this new rule
framework which cleaned it up and
allowed for the distribution yeah yeah
exactly and you know they obviously did
a lot of things really well
um and then you know so they bought it
in 2002 and did all those things and
most of the things there's a few that
are really stupid most of things were
really smart like uh kicking the head of
a grounded opponent it's really dumb
because the only time
you would ever actually do that is
generally when they're knocked out right
you hit them they fall down and then you
kick them also it's like why is that
necessary you know but say like uh a 12
to six elbows something that's banned
it's like you do like this right so your
elbow goes from 12 to six straight down
and it was because some dumbass karate
guy said you could kill someone doing an
elbow like that
well okay listen why can you go like
this right well I'm not going I'm going
at an angle or like this where I'm going
like this but I can't do this it's just
it's Preposterous right why that one
thing is bad or you know another one
that's oh wait the referee I didn't know
this the referee is sitting there and
trying to determine did you go 12 to 6
or did you go like one to seven yeah
yeah so you cannot go straight you can't
go straight down like this with an elbow
yeah and but how do they see that it's
dumb well I mean Jon Jones the I think
he's only ever lost one fight and it was
because of DQ and it was because of that
he did yeah he 12 to six double uh Matt
Hamill I believe
um yeah so um yeah but it's a really
stupid rule but then there's another one
like neem to the head of a grounded
opponent so in one championship by far
in Asia you can you can do that and like
in my take it's a really good fighting
technique because what what you want
from Mixed Martial in my opinion you are
fighting to emulate real life with some
of the [ __ ] taking like an eye gouge
or uh in the nuts you know like throwing
sand yeah so like if you're holding
someone in for headlock and wrestling so
I have you you're heading your arm
holding you down I can't strike you
because I'm using my hands to hold you
right but if I have my knees now I can
actually knee you and I can cause damage
and you're in a you're in a compromised
position which you are in a compromised
position right and uh so you know
there's certain things that are probably
still legal that you could probably make
legal and make it a little more
realistic of a fight but yeah they did a
really good job and then obviously then
The Ultimate Fighter was like 2005 and
that this sport explodes that's when it
explodes yeah so they had the reality
show component of the people we're into
and then you know they had the forest
Griffin Stefan Bonner which was in the
season finale that everyone kind of even
if you don't know mixed martial arts you
kind of remember that because this is
two dudes just freaking throwing down
and uh yeah this isn't it after that
boom it took off and then honestly
during Corona when Dana had the balls to
to keep everything going you know he's
one of the first post towards to start
up again actually right here in Florida
in Jacksonville
um they kind of hit another like boom
and kind of went up again yeah the thing
that's fascinating to me as you said
wrestlers work hard sometimes even
harder than uh other uh disciplines and
the UFC when people see this like these
guys are in shape they're obviously
working hard uh and uh they're going in
there they are just absolutely
destroying each other right in many of
these fights but I think back to like
high school he always knew who the
wrestler was because there was two
things that they would do actually three
things one they all smelled horribly
right two is I remember there was a
couple of guys that would walk around
with these cups they were always
spitting in the cups I'm like what are
you spending the cup for like we're
trying to cut weight because a lot of
you just like go like work out or
whatever yeah but like that we can talk
about why they were doing that but that
and then the third thing was they all
hung out together and just no one messed
with them right like like nobody really
messed with the football team no one
would mess with like most of the sports
but like for whatever reason the
wrestlers like you never just knew you
you're like they kind of sort of know
how to fight and like let's just like
leave them over there and like not screw
with them uh but like talk about
spitting in the cup like in high school
it was such a ridiculous thing right
people would be like why are they doing
that and then when you start to learn
about it you're like oh wait a second
like they don't want to do this they
have no they should be spinning okay all
right well that would be okay so oh
where did I start well yeah first let me
step back first so when you don't mess
with the wrestlers because it like you
said you actually said it earlier it is
a little bit like a fight yeah it's a
physical confrontation you can't there's
a few things you can't do but it's kind
of a fight in school you aren't gonna uh
I gouge someone or like you know like
try to kill them yeah so like actually
most School fights maybe there's a
couple punches them but they end up in
wrestling so like I think that's one of
the main reasons yeah so I think one of
the things you know Max and I uh so we
own five wrestling academies in
Wisconsin and we we really push back and
I think all almost all of America is I
don't say we're there yet but we're
close with the weight cutting is not
beneficial okay uh I so I have theories
on historically why people think cutting
weight is is good for you or um good for
is it good for your success
um but you know over the course of high
school wrestling season an athlete will
have to make weight somewhere around 20
times right between dual meets and
tournaments and all this stuff and so if
you're really focused on losing weight
and spitting in a cup and doing all
these other things
um you're not going to be focused on
getting better at wrestling you're not
going to enjoy it nearly as much because
um even if you're tough cutting weight
sucks even when you're adult cutting
weight sucks
um these guys look miserable I mean a
cutting weight's miserable it just
generally speaking and explain for a
second like what goes into cutting away
like when someone's serious about it
what are all the things okay so I was
good generally High School I would
advise kids cut almost no almost no
weight right
um you know so if you weigh 170 pounds
and the weight classes will just do if
you're 173 and the weight class is 170
the next one's up 183. like for someone
that big to lose three pounds it's like
really minimal like maybe a little less
that day and maybe get a work cut it and
boom you're 170 you know but if you were
saying well Russell 160 well that's kind
of a long ways away it's 13 pounds
um now for like a UFC fighter now
they're going to only make weight so I
said at a high school season probably
make weight 20 times
UFC guy is going to make weight three to
four times per year right
additionally it's going to be a day
before weigh-in right so high school
wrestling college wrestling it's a one
hour win you weigh in and then an hour
later the competition begins oh wow yeah
yeah so meeting so if you're cutting a
lot of water weight you're not going to
compete well yeah right you're just not
going you're dehydrated you're
dehydrated you feel like crap yes and
yeah so so like it's just a really bad
idea why do they do that uh well I got I
have my historical reasons of course but
for um for for fighting it makes sense
because yes in a 24-hour-ish period you
can feel significantly better than what
you did right that makes sense to me
yeah there's a lot of guys and and
actually as an adult adult male
specifically I mean females lose weight
but not nearly as rapidly
um sweating I mean I can I I and I'm not
on probably the high end of the spectrum
I can sweat five to seven pounds in an
hour right put some warm clothes on get
it going and weight comes off like that
you know for real like get it going what
would you do was I mean well okay so the
key is to not work too hard if I'm
cutting weight I don't work too hard
right so I'll get it I'll work hard for
about 15 to 20 minutes I'll start
sweating hard and then I don't gotta
work that hard I'm gonna overwork myself
like what do you do in that 15 to 20
minutes I'm fascinated it might be
running right it might be hitting mitts
um I know like fighting so it's like
it's like normal things it's not some
crazy thing where you got like a trash
bag on yeah but you're like you want it
you want to get your heart rate up okay
that's one more high school kids like so
high school the spit in the cup it's
like just they're being wimpsed they
don't want to go work out it's
ridiculous interesting so like if I ever
saw my kids doing that I'd stop this is
ridiculous just go freaking work out
like you know what I'm saying stop
spitting the cops all they're trying to
do is just get there and you're not
going to lose barely any weight you're
going to lose like you know over the
course of if you've been for a couple
hours you might lose like half a pound
or three you're not gonna lose anything
it's just ridiculous you know so just
like stop dude you look you look
Preposterous I mean honestly if you want
me to go like deep down in the human
psyche yeah those kids probably want
attention from other kids about the
plight of what they're doing right in
hindsight that is what it appeared to be
for sure is it is like I'm a wrestler
this is part of the wrestling club I
want a little bit of attention I want
people to know how tough this is that's
yeah I mean that's human beings like
they want attention for specific things
unfortunately so um well okay so my
historical thought process on why people
cut weight I don't think I've ever said
this on air I've talked I've talked to
other people about this is um right uh
we know correlation and causation aren't
the same thing okay well way back when
we go far enough back in wrestling
um
the toughest people won the matches
because there wasn't there wasn't a lot
of moves it was kind of like who's the
toughest is probably going to win
because they're stronger and they're
meaner and Etc et cetera because there's
not a high level of technique or thought
process or all the things and so then
the toughest people can also probably
cut the most plate because they're the
toughest you know so whether whether or
not they would have cut the most weight
they probably were going to win because
they were the toughest and so then a lot
of people then correlated those things
oh that guy cut a lot of weight and he
won I have to cut a lot of weight in
order to win also interesting you know
and so I think it was like highly
correlational and not causational
because even like um you know in current
ERA you know a guy like Jordan Burroughs
who you know he's one of the best ever
but he in the Olympics wrestles at 74
kilograms which is 163 pounds well he
went up
um and challenged It On full wrestling
he challenged this kind of David Taylor
Who's the world champion at 86. they're
both from America 86 kilograms which is
20 what 22 pounds I'm messing up the
kill it's like I think it's 22 pounds
higher and he lost but it was four it
was four to four right so I don't
explain why it's not tied but it's four
to four meaning that like those guys are
kind of far apart Weight Wise but
wrestling is wrestling if you're really
good at wrestling a few pounds doesn't
really matter all that much you know if
you're highly skilled you're highly
skilled you can wrestle someone who's a
few pounds bigger than you and it's fine
how big of a jump was it so you're uh
this illustrious wrestling career in
college Olympics and then you go out to
Asia yeah and when you're in Asia like
how big of a leap is it to go from
wrestling to actually like fighting in
the cage
um
not for me it wasn't that big at all
um yeah I don't know I just always like
I mean it's one of the big reasons why I
did MMA I mean there's a couple right
one was there's no money in wrestling at
that point in time
um
that I just kind of liked fighting I you
know I enjoyed watching it obviously
even in the early days I was watching it
when it wasn't popular when tough came
out then I watched it a lot my college
buddies watched a lot a few of them
ended up fighting and having a lot of
success uh but I always just like
fighting you know and so for me it
wasn't really all that different I I've
just kind of always enjoyed and still do
enjoy combat yeah uh do you guys get a
lot of fights in college I did not
um that's not saying other people didn't
but yeah I was generally kind of even
tempered I actually never I still have
never drank
um so I was the one kind of watching out
for everybody else or like you know if
they got in a fight then I'm like all
right you know you got to go we gotta
get you out of here you know I was one
taking care of everyone so no I
generally didn't get in any fights
um probably just that I didn't get angry
all that much and you know obviously if
especially if you're a wrestler and you
get the fight there's probably a lot of
negative things that can happen to you
also yeah of course
um so as you kind of go through your
career uh what was Asia like we've
talked about this before but like one of
the things I I've learned more and more
about UFC MMA and like the history of a
lot of the stuff uh it seems like most
of America was like completely unaware
of what was happening in Asia and now
there's maybe a little bit more
awareness between the two
um well yeah I mean one Championship
specifically they signed that uh I'd say
Amazon Prime video deal right so they're
on Amazon Prime I don't know if it's
once a month or I don't know exactly
what the Cadence is but actually
um Japan specifically so one
Championship side of Singapore but they
do it they have cards kind of everywhere
um but Japan specifically had this
organization called Pride uh which was I
don't recall when it was founded
probably somewhere in the mid mid to
late 90s and they were kind of I don't
know if you'd say the best but we would
always see viral Clips in the US yeah
like you wouldn't see anything and then
you just see this clip and you'd be like
yo I don't know where that person came
from but like that was crazy yeah well
so they I mean they had you could
definitely argued they had a better
roster than the UFC for a while for a
while there the UFC actually ended up
buying them along with a few other
organizations but um yeah I mean one of
the things that was hilarious about
Pride was that they they
not only allowed Peds they encouraged
Peds what yes so I have you know I've
had some friends and they said you know
they would say they would go over there
to fight and the owners you know it
would say specifically on the contract
we do not test for Peds right or
steroids or anything but they would say
hey um
you're looking a little soft do you need
anything is there anything we can get
you
really yeah yeah so I mean so that and
that was a and some of these guys were
like almost Larger than Life in that
sense you know and then um you know most
of them came to the UFC and had a
relatively similar amount of success
there was a few that came over and
especially when you saw to started
testing in UFC they you know there's
some of them you could look at the
records and they were like like this
it's almost it's almost insane to me I
would think that I've never taken them
but I would think if I did take them
they would have a small boost on my
performance maybe I get a little
stronger a little better endurance
um
but some of these dudes they literally
were like World Champ level and then
they were like one and seven and you're
like what you think PD's gonna have that
big of an impact oh yeah for sure I mean
the most obvious case the one that like
is uh yeah he's got some names well it's
almost indisputable and listen I cannot
prove that well actually I think he got
busted in early days
so I can't prove this idea but a guy
like Vitor Belfort if you I don't know
can we pull pictures on the screen no I
always love that we need a screen back
here so I can pull so you guys can see
these but like I mean he is like oh my
God like you look at him like you're
like holy crap and then he go usada
comes in and you see a picture of him
and you're like wait was that the same
guy I wish you could see a picture right
now so you could see that the difference
between the two bodies yeah and it's
just like and but there's a handful of
people who you you don't know that they
took anything like there's no proof I I
actually think he did test positive at
some point
um do you think the sport would be
better off if people just were allowed
to no no no
um
well I guess you say that like it's a
no-brainer but I feel like there's a lot
of people who would argue it would be
better off I mean better off if you're
if you're saying strictly for my or your
entertainment I think you have an
argument okay if you think of like the
but the athletes in this sport because a
lot of this stuff there's not really
much long-term data on the effect
effects of it right and then there's
also not long-term effects on
um and you know this is one of the
reasons I I don't say I got out but you
know I stopped sparring for a while
because it's like there's no super
long-term debt on like CTE and brain
trauma and stuff like that and so now if
you're telling me well I'm gonna let you
take a whole bunch of steroids and get
better at giving people brain trauma you
know like I don't know it feels like a
really dangerous do a lot of Fighters
talk about the brain stuff uh not really
no I mean so for me
um
I I watched concussion it was actually I
was actually flying to a fight in Asia I
watched concussion oh it's kind of
sketchy and you got one or you watching
no no I watched the movie remember the
movie oh yeah yeah so um so the movie
came out and I watched him like oh man
and I'm you know Mike you know what I'm
gonna still keep fighting I literally
stopped sparring that was 2016 and I
didn't Spar anymore because I'm like
well why am I taking all this brain
trauma in practice like that's just
unnecessary so Michael I'm still gonna
fight but so I did like a lot of pad
working on the simulated stuff in
practice
um but then you know I kept reading up
on it and I'm very I'm very skeptical
because there was a study that came out
later on CTE that I thought was just
completely Preposterous and it said 99
of people who played football for more
than one year have CTE uh which so if
you think like well that's like 94 of
American males above the age of 40. uh
and then I said but then it said this
was the one that really put me off it
said 87 of people who played only one
year football still developed it and
you're like wait okay so that's gonna be
like everybody so basically if you just
get hit in the head at all ever yes so
that was I'm like okay because obviously
if you put the threshold low enough yeah
you know you can get a bunch of you can
make these results that look really damn
big and you put a bunch of people over
the threshold by putting the threshold
low and so I think I think the jury's
probably still out on that and then you
know um where my brain goes is too is uh
lots of times these people who
maybe find a cage for a living or if you
put NFL in like 70s and 80s and 90s
because it provides test run it's like
you probably had
um a really high threshold for risk and
a lot of you it's probably doing PDS
they're probably doing uh two Lawrence
Taylor was taking cocaine here
recreational drugs right late night
partying yeah so it's like out of all
these factors all mixed together in this
so that's still the wildest Sports story
of all time to me I don't care what
there's nothing that anyone will ever
tell me why I was was doing what cocaine
before the match uh I don't think it was
actually before I think it was like a
day one day before yeah I think I'm
pretty sure he came out and said that
did he get busted ever for it he got us
before cocaine yeah yeah but like for
like because he did it fought and then
got tested right after the fight or it
was like this is why I wish we I wish we
had a screen we could bring up here okay
Jon Jones definitely got busted for it
yeah I I don't when it was I wanted well
so okay so I think it was during a fight
because with usada they have sub they
have substance list that is in
competition right so there's some
substances they'll test for out of
competition right so if I come to the
gym and you're training I'll test you
for this list and they just show up and
they're like let's go let's go pee pee
or blood right or both oh got it yeah
but in competition there's some other
ones that are get added to the list
right so I I think I'm pretty sure
cocaine's one of them or other records
and our guys this is a dumb question but
are guys like ducking them like yo
they're here
runs out to Jon Jones he's coming up a
lot yeah the big story is Jon Jones hid
under the cage
literally of course of course someone
did that right like like if they're
there and you think there's a risk of
getting busted
then yeah I mean it's like human nature
like dude go like go in the closet go
under the cage whatever and so and tell
them I'm not here like is that like oh
crap that someone did that you get you
get three whereabouts it's called
whereabouts failures so what you saw it
up
um I haven't been in the pool for a
couple years so actually I actually I
piloted in 2019 I piloted this thing
where they were it was connected to your
phone so they could see where you're at
which I thought that was tremendous
because otherwise you got to fill stuff
out right and then if I say I feel like
I liked it that they knew where you were
yeah yeah because I didn't want them to
be like I mean okay because when I was
in usada in when I was training for the
Olympics I mean at that point in time
this is 2007-8 you had to fill out
paperwork and fax it right and so you
had to do your schedule three months at
a time so if I told you
um hey I was gonna be here from uh what
time I get here 10 30 10 30 to 12 30 or
whatever right and so I put that on my
schedule well first of all I know my
schedule three months ahead of time yeah
but if I did put it on my schedule and
then you said hey actually can we go at
noon right and they showed up here at 10
30. I would have an hour to show up
otherwise I'm going to get a whereabouts
failure interesting right and so now
what now in in current landscape with
email and text it's man You Gotta Be You
kind of gotta be trying to miss a whole
bunch of them yeah but back then it was
like you had to you know if I want to
change something I'm gonna have to fax
paperwork somewhere like well I gotta go
find a fax machine you know what I'm
saying yeah it's kind of pain in the
butt and so when they show up uh I
recently saw oh I'm gonna mess it up
Costa no I think it was it uh I don't
want to say names because I'm going to
mess it up but I came across the NFL
player and NBA player uh I think the NBA
player and he said it was for the
Olympics you want to play in the
Olympics and he used a uh uh fake dick
and uh for the uh looks at your dick so
this is this was the question I think he
was talking to Shin uh I think it was
Shannon sharp I think uh and basically
uh he had a fake one and he went in uh
to go pee and he said they didn't look
and he just used the fake one and you
know he made it look like he was peeing
but he had the fake one and uh it was
clean uh p and he he made it and I think
he went to the Olympics uh but I've
always wondered because like in college
they 100 are not letting anything go
yeah like no you sat around generally
he's supposed to you know not to get two
provided on these cameras but you're
supposed to like pull your pull your
thing down here and then you lift your
shirt up here you know so you're you're
so they can see exposed yeah so they can
see that there's none of that stuff
going on is there a lot of PEDs in
college you think or not uh I mean they
they test relatively frequently there
was actually unfortunately there was
just in wrestling there was two D3 kids
that won Nationals one at 1a7 last year
and one heavyweight who I believe got
busted so yeah I know right uh but in
right I'm sure there are but how many
kids actually get busted it's it's
really not I feel like it's easier to
trick people in college than it is at
the UFC uh
um which is like like the the pool of
athletes is so much bigger right yeah
every wrestling team at every College
sure yeah the group of people who are
trying to figure that out is probably so
much smaller than uh like on like on a
per you know drug tester to like uh uh
wrestler basis compared to the UFC and
also they kind of know like who's in
who's out who who are we paying
attention to who are we not who's coming
up with the fight you know like you can
almost like start to back into like what
would the cycling but the other thing in
MMA is there's also way more money in it
right and so um when there's way more
money and you have resources to figure
things out so I think there's probably I
mean okay so if you look at you can go
back and you and you saw this website
and see who's failed and like the amount
of wrestlers that have failed something
since like 2008 it's like a really small
number like they're they're interesting
failures but not a lot and you know so
they're testing you got three sales
wrestling men's women's and Greco
um and they're testing probably the top
five or six people per weight class
um so it's not quite as many as UFC but
it's it's a super amount yeah but you
saw here you saw it in UFC you're seeing
kind of a lot of failure you know so you
just kind of extrapolate that and say
well if this maybe we're failing there's
probably a lot of people who are also
doing it either getting away with it or
maybe they have better methods of doing
it where they know they can pass tests
because if you watch I mean you probably
watch Icarus right like they knew how to
beat the tests yeah I also think there's
just a lot in other countries
specifically there's a lot of just pay
pay the like I'm not even gonna take the
test yeah you just pay someone off and
uh well in Icarus they were helping the
the Russian anti-doping so you thought
is actually trying to catch us like they
are not trying to help us rusada was
helping them figure out how to pass the
test while still taking the substances
yeah so that was that movie was wild
wild I don't know if you remember that
yeah yeah well the part that it uh was
it the filmmaker is like taking drugs
over like Zoom or whatever and he's like
doing it and his point was like this is
crazy how much more uh performance I get
out of my body by doing this and he's
like no [ __ ] no wonder they're all
trying to take this stuff yeah well you
know what I thought was fascinating
about that part of it was um he actually
didn't do that much better in the race
so his numbers were all way better like
it was like power output or whatever it
was we're like way better but then when
it actually came to doing the Race So
the one year you did the race clean and
then the next year he doped he didn't do
that much better than actual Racers I
found that part to be uh really
fascinating and I wish they would have I
and I know the movie took a different
turn because the movie took a different
turn because of you know who that guy in
rajenko ended up being but I wish they
would have discussed kind of like more
about the second year and why his
performance wasn't that good despite his
numbers and everything being way way up
all I know is Sammy Sosa and Barry Bonds
aren't in the 75 home runs or whatever
but wasn't everyone in that era doing
something of course but the whole point
is like it's kind of like uh Aaron judge
right like they they see the numbers and
they're like yeah we get what the real
the real record no no no no he just hit
a 60-second home run right and so
there's still this like yeah we know
what the record is but also there's like
uh uh the purist still appeal to the 61
right and so I think that there is this
uh very weird recognition of okay
somebody did at one point hit over 70.
but also like asterisk whatever but
weren't the pitchers doping too that was
because I was kind of a baseball fan so
if there they're doping they're hard to
hit too so it's kind of like an
equivalent my favorite is they've gone
back and forth on like the stuff that
they put on their hats like the uh oh
yeah like slick stuff or whatever yeah
and then you've got like the uh tar on
the bat like all this stuff so it's like
look where's the line and um if you
think about
you know there's a a world where
athletes used to smoke cigarettes eat
hot dogs they do all the stuff in the
Dugout right yes and then somebody was
like I'm a stop smoking cigarettes but
I'm still gonna drink beer and eat hot
dogs yeah and somebody else was like I'm
gonna stop drinking beer and eating hot
dogs and like somebody was like I'm
gonna go for a run someone's like I'm
gonna lift weights and like like there
has been this progression right like
Babe Ruth looks like an average you know
50 year old male today yeah and he's out
here hitting bombs right but what about
in the set in the 70s in baseball so I
used to love all sports and I really
read a lot of biographies they had these
things I can't remember what they're
called now like Greenies maybe where
they were like they were like uppers
they were some type of amphetamine that
that was of course anyone could grab in
in the dug uh or sorry in the in the
locker room but like okay so you do that
that's not allowed let's say right but
like gatorade's allowed yeah right and
now again Gatorade is focused on helping
you recover yeah right electrolytes like
the whole thing so it's like we have
made decisions as to what's allowed and
what's not and I know before everyone
freak sounds like they're talking about
steroids and Gatorade right but like
comp doesn't know the difference
but like when you look at this there is
a world where uh medicine and technology
is going to continue to like what if
somebody says you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna put a chip in my brain that's
yeah like is that gonna be allowed I
don't want to discuss who is it on
someone who's done Lex talking about
that and it kind of freaked me out a
little bit but like what was his name
are we going to allow athletes like is
there going to be a a brain enhanced
Division and a non-brain enhanced
division yeah that's gonna be weird
right like what's better taking PDS or
putting a brain in your chip and or
putting a chip in your brain and like do
you get faster reaction time from the
chip yeah I don't actually I actually
had this theory on on the specifically
in a box steroids and Peds okay um
because I I think you're right I think
there's you know there is uh there you
know it's maybe tough Tougher Than
People want to admit to draw the line of
where we're gonna draw the you know the
line of what you can and can't use but I
think they're really negative
connotations towards steroids because
they don't necessarily have those in a
lot of the countries it's
american-centric specifically is because
everyone Associated the Communists of
using the steroids right and it was the
Cold War and so anything they're doing
is is really is really bad you know the
East Germans and the Russians and CCP
yeah so um those dudes did look stacked
like they were given to women too
remember it really messed them up it was
bad it was not good can you imagine that
being your job well there was a bunch of
I believe there's a bunch of women's
records I I hope I'm right on this I
wish I needed someone to fact check me
right now while I'm saying all these
things I believe there's a whole bunch
of women's records from the era in track
and field that still haven't been beaten
really because they because they were
using such uh you know so many
performance enhancers and then obviously
it started having really negative
effects on their just everyday life so
they backed off on it yeah yeah I do
wonder how many people in business take
Peds like Jeff Bezos he's doing
something my guy's doing something oh
he's obviously he made it just be
working out no not but that's why it's
like okay listen all right so you asked
me earlier like about PDS and MMA and
when you're trying to cause harm to
another person I think there's probably
for me the line is a lot more clear if
you're talking about baseball ah I'm
trying to hit a ball like I don't give a
damn much because it's less about you're
hurting other people and it's more just
what you choose to do with your own body
yeah so that you know that would be more
like I don't care quite as much I mean
you still have the competitive nature of
like if you and I are trying to make a
majorly team and you're taking it now do
I feel like I have to take it in order
to you know see that thing uh but we
talk about like Muhammad how is basil 50
60 something like that uh he wants to
take some of these things like whatever
yeah like okay you're not supposed
anyone just go do it yeah yeah and he's
doing something he's right obviously uh
and it could literally part of what I'm
always like careful of is like it could
just be like hormone optimization yeah
or it could be like he's getting
injected with things right and maybe
those are the same thing maybe those are
two different programs whatever uh but
also it goes back to
is there a problem with it right like
yeah if you go to okay uh so I invested
in a company they do
um uh testosterone enhancement yeah
right and uh I've been scared shitless I
I haven't taken the product or anything
so I'm like I don't know
I just don't know enough I don't know
the science right but like it's
fascinating to me that they've done a
bunch of work that people who are using
it these people are not like Joe Blow on
the street at like you know Gold's Gym
who are like oh let me just get whatever
the guy next to me has these are super
educated you know high-income people
who've done the work usually under a
Doctor Who's recommending whatever
and a lot of the benefits they talk
about are not like get washboard abs
getting massive biceps yeah it's like
mental Clarity higher energy like things
that people are like sure yo I would
like that like I drink six cup of coffee
a day because I'm trying to you know get
clarity right so like it does feel like
we focus on the physical attributes but
there are mood energy Clarity you know
mental Clarity whatever that I think
most people are actually okay with maybe
oh yeah yeah I don't care about a Jeff
Bezos or a business person doing
whatever they're doing and I think um I
think it's probably at this point more
than say 10 15 20 years ago uh money
going into that right there's a lot of
people who want to figure yeah how do I
feel as good as possible as long as
possible
um I was just listening there's that guy
in Rogan uh Brigham Bueller kind of
talking about that what's he saying uh
well he was talking about which I almost
I freaking tried to do it twice and it
failed but stem cells I was gonna go to
Colombia really yeah in 2020 me
um
uh or was it
stem cell there so explain what like
what's the purpose of it uh so my I'm so
it's not like they're terrible my
shoulders kind of like doesn't you know
lost a range of motion my hips not this
the the so I had surgery on this one
this one's not that great uh my brother
has some neck issues and some back
issues so uh and I just heard really
positive
um things like they take your stem cells
no no no uh it's called Uh so I believe
uh so there's two ways to pronounce
mesenchymal or mesenchymal okay
um and they're supposed to be like
really really good for your body's
regeneration
um and I was gonna go one time and I
can't remember when something happened
in the second year they told me I had to
get vaccinated and I said um it forced
me to do nothing right I'm out right the
Columbia government said we're gonna hit
you up with stem cells but you also have
to take them out so I might go back at
some point I don't know but usually want
stem cells in their positive effect he
was also talking about um for his for
his self
um he was overweight and trying to get
in shape and he couldn't figure out why
and so he took a big blood panel and uh
his testosterone was really really low
and once he got that back up to like I
guess normal levels like everything
started getting a lot better so I think
there's going to be a lot of a lot of
research going into like health and
wellness and how do we feel as good as
possible as long as possible you saw the
Dana White thing where he said he got
the blood panel done and he lost like 30
pounds or whatever yeah it feels like
that was the single greatest ad for
anything in the world yeah it was just
like yo this changed my life yeah
absolutely I mean I I this is like
totally off topic but I was just
thinking I actually almost went like
Instagram live just to talk sometimes I
feel like I don't know if you ever do
this but it's like you just need to talk
about something and so you just want to
talk and you want people to hear you and
like you don't really care about that
what did you want to talk about how fat
everyone was in Las Vegas I was just
there a couple days ago really it felt
like oh my God why is everyone so like
average people just walking around like
bro do you understand you live in
America I know I know
I understand but it seems like for I
don't know what was hitting me but it
seemed like extra fat and it was like
how how do you people not realize this
is having such negative long-term
effects on your body on your mind and
all of these things you know and so yeah
and then you know just coupled with a
couple of those podcasts it's like I
think people are just so
um
not all people because I think I think
highly successful people are really into
their health right now and like figuring
out how do I do this best how do I take
care of myself how do I age well
um but there's a lot of America who's
just like jamming whatever fast food
food's kind of unhealthy whatever
medicine my doctor gives me I'm taking
that whether you know what I'm saying
like it's like I think there's a lot of
Americans who probably cure the health
problems by losing 70 pounds and just
working out on a daily basis here's this
isn't as much of a hot take today as it
probably was five years ago maybe even
10 years ago uh I think that a lot not
all but a lot of the mental health
issues in America are due to bad diet
bad uh exercise habits like all the like
Health stuff and I recently had a guy
who's a a heart surgeon he came on he
was talking about the relationship
between metabolic health and mental
health and so like we love to talk about
the mental health stuff right as a
society and things more so entered the
like lexicon any kind of culture or
whatever uh and I think it's well
documented yeah that people are
unhealthy but there isn't like this
connection and so it's again even it was
ten percent ten percent of people who
have a mental health challenge obstacle
or problem if they could simply eat
better and work out and that would cure
that or or maybe even just mitigate it
to some degree like that seems like a
thing we should go do tomorrow yeah yeah
right absolutely but that's not the
thing that gets told it's like take this
medicine do this like yeah I don't know
why well so not men you're not so you're
taking me right down the path of like
all the different Instagram lives I've
thought about doing I actually do this
mental Monday so I do want a week and I
was actually just probably gonna do this
one I had a different one planned for
today but I was probably gonna just put
this one into place because I've read
these two books recently and they both
what are the books uh it was meditation
by Marcus Aurelius oh my gosh I'm
reading the name of the second one what
was it about
um
it's about uh it's that damn journalist
who does the undercover journalism
what's his damn name
um uh project Veritas I don't know uh
O'Keefe okay yeah James O'Keefe yes his
book I don't recall what the name of the
book is right now but he was talking
about man those are really yeah but it
was uh you know
doing hard things and then so with my
daughter I talked about I genuinely
think the mental health stuff in America
is because we have we have too much
times and our lives are too easy yes
I'm like dude you're out like like I
think about America 100 years ago and
you're a farmer and you're out working
in the fields all day you ain't got much
time to think about how you feel like no
you just gotta keep picking the corn or
whatever you know like your life is hard
or you know instead of driving somewhere
you know you gotta walk somewhere right
I mean like life is just hard and you're
worried about how do I get done with my
day and how to do things and you know
I'm sure the world is much better today
than it was 100 years ago but there
there's something to be said there and
then so then to pair that with the books
it's like
what I was thinking was because I was
thinking about my athletes and you know
because a lot of talks go to my athletes
and it's on the wrestling page is
why do so many people want the easy way
you know and when we think about
positive things when you think about
like what you look up to and what
inspires you you always think about that
person who did that hard thing who
overcame that adversity who has this
amazing story and you are inspired by
them and you're like wow you know that
person he freaking grinded it out it was
so amazing what what they did you know
and but then a lot of people like what's
the easiest way I can do this it's like
no like that's that's not that's not
what you should want you should accept
that it's going to be hard if you want
something great you got to accept that
it's gonna be hard and you've got to be
totally okay with that and you gotta
Grant I mean that's why I didn't give a
book talk at the late cling convention
last week and um you have a chapter on
attitude which is like exactly what uh
yeah I I feel like it's just knowing
that the hard stuff is the good stuff
for you yeah but it's so okay so it's
like anything really good is gonna take
you so many years of hard work you know
I talk about like it was 15 and it was I
thought it was a couple but it's like
that was completely delusional but I
said I wanted to go to the Olympics
um and given Where My Success was at
that point in time there was probably no
good basis for that I just figured
that's what I was going to do
um but that it was eight years away
eight years you know and there are so
many points along that Journey where
it's like hey you hit this adversity and
you think like [ __ ] am I Really Gonna
Make it you know like I had I ended up
being really good in high school but
then I go to college and like I you know
I say the funny thing you played
football uh and that's I don't want I
don't pick on you but it's kind of easy
because if you're okay if you're not if
you're not good in football they're like
hey man like you go stand over there and
like hang out for a little bit if you're
not good in wrestling you're getting
your face rubbed in the mat you know
like if you're not the starter if you're
not the guy you're getting beat up on by
the guy every day you there's no ghost
sitting on the sidelines you're getting
faced over the mat so it's like it's
very humbling and so you don't like my
freshman year I went to college and it's
like I'm getting my ass kicked like
every single day it's like dude I want
to go to the Olympics I was really good
in high school I'm literally getting my
ass kicked every day you know why didn't
you quit because yeah I mean so honestly
that was probably for my wrestling
Journey that was the the part where I
most said am I can I really do this can
I really do this this is what I want to
achieve can I really do this and you
know that was where you know the
scrambling came and all this stuff but
it was just like
yeah you got to make that decision like
no I'm gonna keep going I'm gonna come
back the next day I'm gonna fight I'm
not gonna get too discouraged and you
know yeah obviously there's a few points
along that Journey where you're like
[ __ ] dude I don't know if I can do this
like I suck like I'm getting my ass
kicked every day but you just keep
coming back you know and then eventually
there's something that happened well I
can tell you I can tell you know I
didn't put this in a book but I can tell
you exactly what happened for me
um you're curious you want to know yeah
of course yeah I got my ass kicked all
fall in the restroom so I go to college
I got my ass kicked all fall I don't
know why I didn't put this in the book I
should put this in there
um and I lost a whole bunch of matches I
only lost I lost eight matches in high
school in my four years of my actual
college for my non-regular year I only
lost eight matches in that fall I lost
10 matches wow you know so it's like I'm
getting my ass kicked in the room every
day and I'm losing the guys who like
aren't really that good and so I'm like
you know having this like can I really
be good like am I really ever gonna be
able to do this and I went back
and it was a non-recognition of the
Improvement I was making because when I
left me and my high school coach were
very competitive like I was starting to
get the better of them a little bit but
he was probably still beating me more
often than not I went back four months
later right so you leave in August I
came back in for a Christmas break and
like he couldn't score me like I really
yeah and it was like oh and then for me
it was like it was it was this mental
hurt of like oh my God I actually got a
lot better I got a lot better like I
didn't realize it because I'm getting my
ass kicked in the room every day and I'm
losing these masters of college guys but
holy moly I got a lot better you know it
was in a click for me and I'm like okay
you know and then I still had some I
still had a few kind of like
maybe maybe a handful of months till I
really started like getting a lot better
but it was like it clicked for me that
day what's fascinating about this uh
Robert Green's got a book Mastery that I
yeah I recently reread the book and uh
and one of the big things is like
everyone thinks Mastery is just genius
or like a stroke of luck or whatever and
he goes through example after example
for example including things like you
know Albert Einstein's uh brother runs
like a publishing shop and so he gets to
understand yeah I'm sorry Ben Franklin's
brother runs a uh publishing chat
whatever Charles Darwin goes on this
like seven year Journey around the world
he's collecting specimens from all these
different places and he like realizes
like oh [ __ ] maybe there's like
Evolution right yeah or whatever uh but
it also talks about like the grind right
it's like these people usually start out
and they have no Mastery yeah and they
go through the apprenticeship phase like
whatever but he talks about this like
essentially decades-long journey to
build the Mastery and so you saying like
I want to go to the Olympics like I'm
not that good right now but eight years
from now it's like pretty much you know
you overlay that to his theory it almost
plays out perfectly because you have to
do every single day for hours a day and
just build up the skill sets until you
get to a point where you're like yo I
can actually do this yeah so there's no
the notion that uh
we should desire something that's easy
it's it's such a flawed notion right
um if you get it easy everyone can have
it you know if it's easy then everyone's
gonna go get it like we we shouldn't
want the things that easy We should
strive for the things that are hard
um yeah so you know that and then like I
go with AWA now who that's asking
Academy my brother and I uh and maximum
High School coach started it and you
know we're 11 years in now and we've
been like in insane strides but it's
like
at no point was that easy you know it
wasn't easy it was the hardest part
about building that business
um well first of all I didn't I actually
you know what's so funny I just met at
the homecoming game in Mizzou I met the
dean of the business school and it was
like I wish I would have taken a
business class I took zero I took zero
you know so I mean for starters I I had
to learn a lot of things the hard way
because I didn't know what the hell I
was doing you know so you and your
brother just get together one day and
you're like yo let's start a wrestling
Academy well okay so he he had some
serious injury issues I kind of said
with that with the stem cell thing
um he had some injury issues after
college and he went and just coached uh
for this family out of out of actually
New York out of college and then it
wasn't enough time you know there was
like it can't take occupy this day so
he's like what else do I do so I'll
start wrestling Academy to kind of go
along with that so he started Wrestling
Academy out there and then our high
school coach was you know the High
School Association have really strict
regulations on how much they can coach
and stuff he kind of always wanted to
coach you around so like hey why don't
we start this and we'll you know it'll
go year round so you can coach all the
time and then and then incidentally I
also moved back to Milwaukee because I
wanted to train a Rufus and so and then
Max then moved back from New York a
couple years later so we've been
building ever since but yeah I mean so
the business aspect was first of like
how do we how do we do this you should
like literally go get a building and
you're like yeah I'll give you a stupid
one and it's like if I would have been
more seasoned I probably would have been
like
go f yourself but we were opening uh our
first Academy and the building inspector
says actually you need this size of uh
air conditioner or something like that
so we we bought a twenty thousand dollar
uh air conditioner because they said we
needed it you know what I'm saying and
it's like I don't know like my a couple
abilities don't have any air
conditioning at all like there's no way
we actually needed that like he freaking
pulled it over yeah it was probably it
was probably honestly it was probably
the building owner and the the city
supervisor working or whatever's working
together to kind of maybe make something
nicer because we thought we could take
that with us when we leave you know
can't uh we cannot so um yeah so there's
something stupid like that you know
where it's like that kind of play disc
in the beginning
um and then I mean I don't want to know
if I want to go into the wrestling
business too much but
um
is it a good business no no I love it I
love it so I'm gonna do it forever but
like uh you know it's you obviously have
like mostly fixed costs uh we talk about
the wrestling Academy stuff and you know
the rent and and the salaries and stuff
like that but um you know any Joe schmoe
and there's a lot of them think they can
start one and they can if they're
compelling enough they can advance a few
people that they know what the hell
they're talking about you know so if you
do that and then three other people do
that and they pull you know the age pull
10 kids
and convince those 10 kids they know
what the hell they're talking about this
this happens right well that's that's 40
kids that we don't have in our Academy
now and
um you know eventually their gig is
going to be up because people realize
they're not really very good at coaching
yep but who knows maybe that's two years
or three years or four years down the
road and so you kind of have these like
mom and pop shops kind of like opening
up a lot and you know the barrier to
entry for something like that is really
low you should just go wrestle them
[Laughter]
right uh in the book by the way I have
to call this out because there's not
very many books I read that have this uh
you have a quote from yourself yes at
the attitude chapter it says every
fighter is only as good as their last
performance you have a great performance
everyone thinks you're the champ you
look like [ __ ] everyone tells you you
suck yeah and she says me
like first of all quoting yourself is
awesome uh but like I do think social
media like that is a perfect example
right when things are going well it's
like everyone loves you when things are
not going well I've literally seen
people who I thought was like that
person's best friend is now like dunking
on them oh really on social of course
but like what you realize is like they
actually weren't best friends you just
thought they were or like the perception
was they were close friends or whatever
yeah
um but obviously not yeah and so it
feels like social media exasperates just
like The Human Condition right yeah and
so you do see people uh fall in and out
of favor very quickly and I wonder how
that plays into whether it's wrestlers
or other types of kids who are growing
up and like I don't know when I was a
kid like we didn't have Twitter yeah
right we didn't have a lot of this stuff
we had AOL Instant Messenger but that
was it I think we're the same age so I
remember that yeah like that was pretty
much it it's like yeah you can talk to
your friends but like the most like
social signaling you could really do
there was like your away message
right or like you're like like maybe
you're a handle or you know you're like
a name or whatever but like can you
imagine growing up now and have Tick
Tock and Instagram I'm like so me and my
wife are uh my wife's trying to Spirit
the thing where where
um uh a lot of the families in our
school agree to not give our kids uh
social media cell phones until eighth
grade
yeah and I think it's great I supporter
on that and I think it's great so all
the kids if none of them have it then
none of them want it correct that would
be the thing because that's what a lot I
mean that's why a lot of people give the
reason why they're giving their kids
phones is because their friends have it
and they're not getting invited or
whatever yeah but um I think I think I
mean to your point I think social media
is a lot for adults to handle
um for real though so I I learned early
on so my and is in the book I talk about
this
um
when I was 15 years old I was a
sophomore in high school
um
I was headed towards the state
tournament okay and someone tells me so
it's the last weekend's sectionals and I
killed everyone and I was really good
that year uh from a state perspective
and they say hey there's these forums
and everyone's talking about you okay
what's for them I don't know what that
is you know like that is 2 000 the year
2000. so I didn't know what that was so
okay I'll go send me the address I'll
check it out whatever so go there and
all these people are talking about me
and you know I was 15. so I'm like no
I'm gonna kick his ass and I'm gonna
kick his ass oh he's like the
competitors are in there no not the
competitors other people talking about
how these other dudes were gonna beat me
at the state tournament you know yeah uh
and so I'm like nope I'm gonna love him
I'm gonna whip him and and all of a
sudden everything really talked about
and then the next week I went whooped
them you know and then I went back on
the forums I pardon all these dudes you
know you're like right you're actually
oh yeah I was partying on them so hard
but uh but then so then I realized like
it's mostly adults you know and then so
then I started like diving into like the
next two years I would just try to
torture these people like with just
doing different stuff to make them angry
and I realized like how easy it was to
manipulate group think and how
groupthink moves what would you do to
like oh like all kinds of like okay one
time I was walking on the street and I
saw this person a little pig and I'm
like hey give me 20 I'll give you 20
bucks I have that and they're like sure
spoiled Pig a blown up okay it was like
uh you know like yeah you know I don't
even know why but anyway so I took in
the tournament you know uh my hair
growing out people really hated that
um because wrestlers are supposed to
have hair like you you know look I look
like a wrestler yeah you look like a
wrestler why you need some more ears but
yeah
um and then I carried a Boombox around
right just all kinds of I put an x on
the mat where I was gonna pin someone a
few times
you know wait wait wait hold on hold on
on the mat you went out there before the
match and put an X like in tape or
something yeah tape you tape a little
accent that's what I'm gonna pin him and
then would you do it yeah
like if you do it then like yeah I mean
no they're still mad of course they're
still mad about it yeah so you but you
so you realize at a young age I was able
to realize like how just like group
think works and how it and you know how
favor goes to and against you it's
obviously I mean crypto we saw this
right it was insane in the last year or
whatever with uh the bear Market hitting
and to me it's like whatever like I'll
be in here the next cycle and the next
cycle I can't get over it I can't get
over you putting an ax on the mat and
then pinning someone there yeah well so
someone else allegedly I guess there's
no video over this because the guy's
older but there's this guy who actually
the pinning trophy I won the I won the
best pair in college twice and the
trophy is the shallows award so it's
named after this guy named way shells
the legend is he did it right so I heard
about him doing it and I'm like I'm
gonna do that too so I did it a few
different times and then yeah you got
the pen award yeah and then I got them
well then it was many years later but
yeah yeah did you ever do it in college
uh I don't don't think I ever did in
college yeah I feel like that's like uh
do it in high school you can get away
with a lot of stuff in college I've done
it I probably should have done in
college
I mean that'd be pretty impressive
imagine if you went to the Olympic match
and went out and just did it that would
be awesome huh
I don't know what the reaction would be
okay I do feel like the Olympics are uh
a little bit crazier like because you
have like the countries like the
national respect and like all that kind
of stuff so if you pulled off that type
of thing like it's like an international
incident right now you'd be a legend oh
100 yeah for sure right the um uh I
always like the uh the track uh the
4x100 or whatever where the guy's got
like sunglasses on and stuff and you're
just like dude that guy don't give a
[ __ ] like he's gonna run as fast as he
can and let's go America right like is
there America always win that one of
course I'm not much okay but but also to
be fair uh uh across all of track and
field like that's really where I think a
lot of people got busted uh for years or
years oh my God for years it was
happening right there was I'm not going
to use names but there was uh well did
they actually get busted or not I went
to high school in North Carolina okay in
uh in Raleigh and uh our high school
track was one of the nicer tracks uh and
so a bunch of these Olympic athletes
would at the track so like you'd like go
out there and like I'm talking about
like the top Olympic sprinters would be
there sometimes and you like walk out of
class and be like
that is CR like they're fast right like
but like this is real and uh a bunch of
them got busted
uh over the following years and uh you
know someone came back or whatever but I
remember thinking just like dude sure
like if they did it they did it whatever
but like I saw them out there working
their asses off right of course they do
both uh right but like I think the
narrative had swung so much of just like
steroid use versus like I don't know man
I'd look outside the classroom and I'd
see them up there running and like
they look like they were sweating well
that was like that's like to me that was
like the Tour de France yeah like I know
Lance like a lot of kind of negative
things came out about him yeah but it
was like that race I don't care what you
use them mug still rode 150 miles a day
or something crazy like it's crazy you
know so and then obviously all of them
in that one again these are these are
not combat athletes right all of them
are on it which is across the board like
100 they're all using so it's like yeah
whatever I'll you know you're pedaling a
bicycle a bicycle like but that's where
I always go like how much time and
effort goes into preventing it versus
just like dude just be like free game
you can take whatever you want who who
can do it yeah I mean with something
like that I mean 2 000 miles of
bicycling or whatever
just let let them take whatever they
want probably were I mean at that point
in time yeah just let them take whatever
they want and see what happens as long
as it's not a sport where you could
literally kill somebody or hurt somebody
right yeah
um I mean I wonder if there's and I
don't know anything about the PDS but
there's probably some level of some
substance there that you could take so
much you would probably kill yourself
right well what I don't know what I
actually think would be more interesting
is just like
legalized it's kind of like the the War
on Drugs right like like dude if they
make weed legal
my guess is that they're going to have
less problems with it yeah right so same
thing here is just like just make it
legal and say whatever you do you have
to do under a doctor's supervision yeah
we'll provide the doctors
yes they should right like like would it
increase the safety of what they're
already going to try to do anyways
probably it's definitely a chance I
don't know some people get mad because
I'm not an expert in uh PD usage in the
cycling industry so that's one funny
thing about um you know podcasts these
days is
um obviously like you and I we say of a
high level knowledge in certain aspects
of our lives right but it's not like
we're expecting about Experts of
everything but so then certain people
say like well if you're an expert you
can't talk about that it's like well why
can't I you go have conversations on the
couch with your buddies about whatever
the hell you want by the way have you
seen the experts talk about some of this
stuff like that they're not exactly the
swords we're still like four pounds like
why can't we talk about something like
this is just two dudes having a
conversation like I'm sure you're gonna
do they get mad at you oh you'll see I
mean I see with like especially you know
who gets it the worst which is I'm sure
he ignores if it's Rogan oh yeah you
know but it's like because I heard the
best description somebody was like Joe
Rogan is sitting in a room with Google
trying to figure [ __ ] out and that's
what everyone else is trying to do too
right like like that's why he is access
to really smart people because of who he
is yeah but so it's like yeah I don't
understand it's not like it's not like
Joe Rogan ever ever says I know
everything you have to listen to me of
course he never says that he's just a
dude trying to figure things out and
it's like every dude when they go to the
bar or they're sitting on the couch with
their buddies they talk about something
like they have some level of expertise
and it's just people having conversation
trying to figure information of course
so when people do it on when you know
they're like pom does know [ __ ] about
bicycle racing why is he talking about
bicycles well I could ride a bike
I'm further along to some people right I
mean that's how I think though right
it's just like I don't know what the
answer is but uh it's interesting to
think about I agree one of the uh things
that I thought would be interesting to
hear your perspective on yeah uh we
talked about brain computer chips going
in the athletes do you ever think that
we'll see humans fight machines uh who
is this uh I gotta look this up now who
is the one that it totally freaked me
out uh because he was talking about
chips in the brain it wasn't Balaji it
was on Lex though I'm gonna look and
somebody was talking about it was
relatively recently okay he was talking
about uh uh what is that term that they
use for when uh Singularity yes to have
the singularity totally oh Ray Kurzweil
oh yeah Ray Ray Kurzweil yeah yeah
famous yeah yeah oh he's super famous he
basically came up with the singularity
concept yes it was freaking me out but
for those I don't know Singularity is
the merging of the human and the
machines together but you know the most
obvious to me and I I don't even know
why I mean it is too stupid for them to
even discuss but it's like okay if I put
them in my brain
how come someone can't hack it
right yeah yeah why can't they say go
murder that guy or or just shut off just
shut off you know like if they put if I
let someone put something on my brain
like surely there's some nefarious
things that can happen I forget the
Netflix series uh in the series
um it's it's like the political drama
series that was like super popular this
one's like the first one to Netflix
today I don't watch any TVs popular so
Homeland was good though yeah um it was
like that but it was uh all about uh
American politics and and this guy was
trying to become president
my wife watched that one yeah so uh I'm
pretty sure it's that one uh one of the
characters has a um a pacemaker uh and
they like think it's gonna be hacked or
it gets hacked or something and I'm like
yo I'm out like I am I am so out but the
problem is that like if you need a
pacemaker like there's not any other
options so like in that situation yeah
yeah but like the brain implant same
thing but like I forget for a second
would you do it someone says you can do
it right now
I one my biggest concern would actually
be the safety of it like I'm a I'm
actually pretty conservative when it
comes to a lot of the stuff like a great
perfect example right is I invested in
the uh testing yeah
business I'm not good
um
yeah wait till like our testosterone
falls off the cliff and then for sure
um
but what about humans and machines going
into a cage and fighting each other well
I just think I I mean I think it's
Preposterous because uh it probably
wouldn't take much to make uh a machine
win right because how are you actually
gonna kill the machine
you know what I'm saying like like this
becomes part of the game right uh it
just seems it would seem so easy for the
machine to win you know what I'm saying
because like say I'm gonna leg kick you
well it's gonna hurt you right what am I
going to leg kick a steel leg of a
machine like that's gonna hurt me not it
but like this is where like you could
see if the public had the option of
watching they would 100 are watching
that man I don't know so I think this is
like uh what was that one show and
someone told me this still existed oh
BattleBots oh yeah yeah someone told me
to still existed really I don't really
watch a lot of TV so I'm not certain
they told me this
um where they tried to create the
machines that would destroy each other
you know
um but that isn't that's not that
interesting to me well okay so that's
what I said I don't think it's that
interesting but um so I think there's
something about like the human body and
everyone knows we all have one right we
all have one body and so to see what
someone else can do with their human
body like fascinates us whether it's
running fast like the 100 or fighting or
trying to hit home runs because there's
a part of us that we can all kind of
feel what that would feel like and if it
was like a robot it would just be weird
I think but like part of me wants to
know like
The Machine's ass or not no you don't
think so hell no
someone's gonna find out come on I think
I'm not fighting that robot all right so
right now would you fight a Boston
Dynamics Boston Dynamics robot is Ben
Astron gonna fight the Boston Dynamics
robot could you beat the robot probably
not because how am I going to hurt it I
think right now you could beat it
um will I pull some wires out or
something like how do I hurt it you'd
have to figure it out
this sounds like a terrible proposition
right but like that's my whole thing is
like right now I think you actually
could beat it yes it'd be athletic
whatever but like you could still beat
it at some point it'll get where no you
couldn't I feel like I mean in a
wrestling match could you could beat the
robot right now
uh well in wrestling match I don't have
to hurt it I always have to skip
but uh I mean because this is this is I
know nothing about robots but I'm just
just thinking like
surely you can make the robot be like 10
times as strong as me
sure so then how am I gonna like do
anything to it scramble I don't know no
I don't know anything about wrestling
right but like if it's strong but slow
like what I'm saying is like right now I
think that the robots are not in a place
where like they are dexterous and agile
and like all these things that you would
need to actually go to wrestling so you
can still beat them now at some point I
agree you won't be able to but right now
I bet she's still so I had this
discussion with Lex when I was on his
podcast about uh him and Dan and her
were talking about grappling robots and
um and then how you could put Ai and
then make them simulate wrestling
matches like they've done this with
chess right and they seem like all
different things that could happen and I
thought that would be fascinating with
wrestling was wrestling at this point
um and I think Jiu Jitsu also about more
of an expert wrestling it's still
evolving at a really rapid rate and so
if you could have robots wrestle you
could they could they could
um move it at a more rapid rate even
than what we're doing right now
um but you know I I know like I don't
know a lot of robots I've seen some of
those videos and they are they are still
a little bit clunky like they don't move
super well but I was I was thinking it's
kind of like I speak to how advanced the
human brain is like if I just might
shoot a single leg right
there's so many stimuli if you were
wrestling each other for you to
understand all at the same time right
how much force am I shooting with how
much speed am I shooting with exactly
where am I going what where is my uh
where is the pressure being angled at am
I trying to sweep behind you am I trying
to go into you right like and so you're
kind of reading all of those at one and
then you're making adjustment to your
body and then if I'm high level right
I'm making an adjustment with my body
and so for a robot who can't like walk
or jump or do things all that well you
know having all those stimuli be
understood it's obviously uh magnitude
is more complex than a game of chess
right chess is like there's no timing
component to it for example right you
just have uh rules of where they can
move there's no pressure component too
like am I putting pressure like here or
is it here or you know like where on
your leg is the pressure happening you
know so um yeah no that would be
fascinated for wrestling robots someday
but it still feels like even if they
didn't know the moves they would still
just be so powerful
that you're not gonna be able to do
things with them yeah
you also boxed yes Jake Paul only once
yeah one time uh why'd you do it
um
because they asked me if I wanted to
and was it just like this will be fun
well okay so first
um you know I see the highlight of him
and uh Nate Robinson and I what was your
reaction when you saw the Highlight
first uh they both suck right that was
it I think they have to go see what I
tweeted to make sure I'm not lying
that's that's something to that effect
you know
um and I was I at this point this is why
I I like I don't get mad about very much
anything but I'm kind of annoyed people
don't give me any leader for this like
at this point it was that was three
months or two months after my hips would
be like I was supposed to be
non-weight-bearing for three months you
know yeah I got fat as [ __ ] because I
enjoy eating and I didn't get to work
out because I can't put a weight on my
leg you know and so then they call me
and like hey would you really want to
fight him and I'm like uh I don't know I
kind of like fighting like I don't know
he probably sucks I'll probably beat him
up sure you know like why not so you
went into it 100 thinking that you had a
shot to beat him yeah absolutely I
thought he wasn't very good and
unfortunately I was wrong um but yeah no
show okay so first um my doctor had said
uh you have to wait a year to do any
like real live activity or wrestling or
whatever and so I'm like well I can't do
it because I gotta wait a year like I
haven't done it I haven't literally
haven't done anything I haven't I
haven't I haven't ran I haven't rode a
bike I haven't lifted weights I haven't
done anything you know yep
um
so I saw this dude John Wayne Parr who's
a kickboxing champ he was kicking a bag
and he just had to have the same surgery
I did and I was like wait like how does
he get to kick it back this is [ __ ]
so I messaged him like Hey you just had
that same surgery I did why are you
kicking a bag already because he was
like I want to say he was like four
months out or something you know when I
was supposed to wait a year and I think
I was on I was on like three months or
whatever you know and so he said to me
back he said well my doctor said three
months I can do whatever the hell after
three months I do whatever I want it's a
way this [ __ ] like why does my
doctor making me wait a year so I called
my doctor so I'm like I called my doctor
I'm like hey man why do I gotta wait a
year and he's like cuz that's what you
that's that's the recovery time you need
I'm like well how come this dude I
stopped picking a bag and it's only been
three months his doctor said that's cool
and he's like well that guy he actually
knew the doctor he's like oh that guy's
got because there's not a ton of people
who do this specific surgery right he's
like oh that guy's got a higher fail
rate than me I said all right what's
your fail rate for your hips and he's
like one in 998.
okay I'll take my chances
so then I started training
all right and so uh when you go
and you're doing the way in doing all
the stuff and everything uh are you guys
cool or were you guys like talking [ __ ]
and I would just say I was kind of
different to him you know kind of like I
was trying to taunt him
um of course it's like entertainment
aspect to it uh we'll just kind of also
just get in his head you know like I
mean kind of what I figured about him is
he hadn't really been in very many real
fights you know and there's something to
it
um you know a lot of people get nervous
when they fight and make mistakes and
stuff like that so that was kind of
where I was at so I mean I I did have a
good three-month training camp
um you know obviously so prior to that
I'm a hip surgery and I was out and then
prior to that I had been retired for uh
10 months or something so I hadn't I've
been doing a lot of wrestling I was in
the wrestling room a lot but no striking
or no other type of mixed martial arts
uh but I did a three good three-month
training camp
um felt pretty good I lost a lot even
though I didn't look like great
physically I had lost a lot of weight
from where I where I started right
because I had no I didn't know nothing
for almost four months with my hip
um yeah and unfortunately like he just
ended up being a lot better than I
thought I mean he beat Tyrant and
Tyrone's significantly better box than
me and now you know he's fighting
Aaronson Silva this weekend and he's uh
you think he can win well actually when
you when you put this out it might be
done already so um yeah I mean well the
oddsmakers say it's close right it's uh
it's not like there's a one's a huge
favor of the they're relatively close
which alone like that's kind of
surprising just to start right because
if it's almost a Jake Paul win just for
the Ops maker to think it's close yeah
because if I would say I was gonna be
Harrison still unboxing you'd say like
yeah like that's funny you know like
it's just not it's not what I ever did I
mean all of my striking mixed martial
arts was more like how do I make contact
with you and then get you on the ground
and beat you up from there that was
everything I always did so
um yeah I knew I knew I wasn't very good
at boxing
um I just thought he also wasn't very
good at boxing you know and then the one
thing that kept coming back to because
uh this water is gone dang uh a lot of a
lot of people said like you know what if
you lose it's like well I don't really
ever care with public things yeah but
when I was in high school
um not not every Friday night but once
in a while we had some boxing those in
my basement and if we didn't have
anything fun to do a bunch of dudes
would come over and we'd be like you
versus you you versus you and we always
thought that was a blast like we always
thought that was a fun Friday night so
I'm like okay if when I'm in my 30s
they're gonna pay me a whole bunch of
money to do something that I literally
did for fun and thought was a fun Friday
night when I was 17. like I'd have to be
an idiot to just not do this yeah like
yeah let's go
I mean I kind of like that mentality
right so when you go and uh he hits you
you're down you get up you realize like
I lost yeah
the next time I think I saw you on the
video feed was you and Amy going through
the tunnel laughing and I was like all
right they seem good yeah people were
upsetting me for that one why okay so
first of all the ref I told the ref like
dude I'm fine like I got knocked down
but like I'm okay I can fight now and he
just said no and I'm like that's
[ __ ] you know so you know but I'm
like well I guess I didn't really care
anyways whatever I'm [ __ ] out of here
and I just left you know
um which actually I don't think I'm
supposed to leave but then you know it
didn't occur to me as a fact it was like
I guess I lost I don't want to be here
anymore I'm going to leave
um and then my wife you know as I'm
leaving my wife is right there and it's
okay so the other thing is it's in a
football stadium
you know and there's no one there so you
know our walk to get out of there is
like 100 meters but um
I mean I didn't really care to prove I
was a great boxer I was hoping I was a
better boxer than him yeah the idea
um and but my wife at that point said
something like hey do you guys Justin
Bieber just opened for you and you're
the main event you know you know
something like that right it was like I
mean the whole
the whole wild like you know there's
Justin Bieber and then there was Snoop
Dogg and then it was just kind of like
it was it was very circus like the whole
the whole thing you know
um and then it was like all right hey
let's go get my money and let's like get
out of here and I'll come back to
coaching wrestling do people know how
much you got paid yeah I mean I made uh
close to a million dollars between all
the sponsorships and everything else
yeah I mean not terrible for something
that I would consider fun Friday night
when I was 17. yeah so like
do you think that that well I was called
like the YouTuber boxing World which I
would argue
uh Jake has escaped he's no longer being
hey you go fight a YouTuber you with her
like now he's got like yeah real
competition right however you want to
measure that
um
do you think that like YouTuber
entertainment boxing stuff has like legs
to it yeah other people are trying I
mean so he has the circus thing
um I mean I guess his last fight didn't
I mean okay there's rumors I'm not
certain this last five wasn't selling
them on that somebody will say that's
why I was canceled
this fight
um which uh I don't want to put this up
but it's happening October 29th some
people are saying it's not selling that
well
um the whole stick is over type thing so
I I don't know like I think he's
actually kind of good at boxing and I
guess we'll see how far he takes it
um
can other people do it I'm not I'm not
sold I think he's a very unique person
to be able to do this right yeah and
like I've talked to him about it
specifically of just like there's if you
think in society in general the ability
to like reinvent yourself over and over
again so like Kim Kardashian's probably
the like epitome of this right really I
don't pay any attention to yourself sex
tape reality TV star entrepreneur
Criminal Justice Reform I personally
believe okay Governor president what
hundred percent oh my God Kim
Kardashian's president I did so let me
ask you guys because I have because I
don't know anything about Kim I I know I
saw another sex tape I know the reality
show I didn't watch it at all
um of which the sex tape for the reality
I actually never seen the other one
um but it's an entrepreneur did she
actually do all of those things because
there's obviously a lot of people who
lend their name to stuff and and they've
and they're at least smart enough to
find really smart people to run their
projects yep there's something to be
said for that for sure right but like
did she actually start those bit like I
am I am personally running asking
Wrestling Academy me and my brother in
the highest coach right
um
I didn't know but the the reason why I
say with pretty high confidence like
she's really involved in this stuff yeah
there's multiple things that she's done
where like you can see it's like the
same Playbook over and over again okay
it's working but then I heard uh or
watched uh her and David Letterman
Letterman's got a like a show on Netflix
or whatever right and uh he interviews
her
I was blown away I was like man she's
like way more articulate than people
would probably give her credit for okay
uh and the way and look she's got media
training she's got all the stuff that
way uh but like it's very easy to see
like that could be the leader of a
business you know if they're talking
saying these things whatever and you're
just like okay like yeah there's more to
this and then you also have to forget or
not forget like
she brings marketing power where like
you post on Instagram right there's a
lot of there's a lot of Founders who are
trying to like build Twitter audiences
so they could like get people to buy
their product yeah she shows up and
she's like uh yeah we can sell stuff one
then between her and her siblings and
everyone else kind of like in that
um uh what you call it like universe or
yeah you know they have yeah cross
promote stuff they like you know what I
mean like it's like there's like things
there for sure that uh that they can do
interesting though why we say reinvent
yourself you know I I think of a is uh
Steve Jobs I mean you know like when you
start reading about him
um like that just that he went and kind
of like saved Pixar For example he
became a billionaire off Pixar first
yeah I mean that's kind of wild like you
know like most people don't think of
when they think of Pixar they don't
think of Steve Jobs but he was highly
influential and bringing that business
back and then putting the effort in
necessary to to get them to the next
level you know and then you think about
like okay what do you do with apple but
then like he made
um iTunes you know for example like who
put music on a phone it was kind of him
you know yeah so you think like that's
kind of who I think oh I think like like
constantly Reinventing themselves and
making new ideas is and I think he
actually almost doesn't get enough
credit as he should for all different
things it is crazy yeah right and I
think the rematch like uh with Jake is
an example his brother also like WWE
star now because he's in WWE dude he I
watched uh like a highlight reel of uh
maybe WrestleMania or whatever one of
the events was
he's athletic yeah like the guy's doing
backflips off of you know the ropes and
stuff he was a pretty good wrestler in
high school Jake wasn't a very good
wrestler but Logan was got it yeah is
that like a a thing that the wrestling
Community talks about uh I don't know a
little bit probably not like are they
are they the most successful wrestlers
of the last like 20 years uh that's a
great question well yeah Jake Lesnar
Jake's supposed to made 50 million last
year allegedly I never believed those
numbers ever
well because I know I've seen mine right
I've seen mine I know what my net worth
is right yeah and I've seen some that
said I saw one said 20 million and I
thought I wish right and I saw one that
said half a million and I thought no way
you know what that's not true at all you
know so it's like somewhere between
those numbers so I've seen by you know
you see those online and you're like oh
well they're not true I I know they're
not true of me yeah and I know I I don't
even know where they got the information
I think they just like made guesses by
knowing a few of my purses or something
so that's that's one the other thing is
uh the business list I think they asked
for verification but it's like a little
uh kind of crazy because
uh they could ask you like what's the
value of the business and if they don't
know the full breakdown they estimate
right
um
what I'll say is uh the numbers are
probably closer than we would guess okay
uh based on some conversations I've had
yeah
um so let's just say that they are he
kind of scammed an nft and crypto Market
too so however we did it
does that make him the most successful
wrestler no I don't know
um who made more money than him well I
mean if we denote that money is the only
way to success but yeah there's a few of
those crypto and nft projects he backed
from
kind of what is going on like who let
him do that type of thing you know I
mean almost it almost makes me you know
how it makes me feel
is like if he was really worth that much
money why would he be backing that
you know what I'm saying it's not like a
Bitcoin or you know or even a a
reputable company like some of the ones
he backed for like wait like what is
even going on here yeah yeah who would
you say is the actual most successful
wrestler like
when you say like hey this is the
representative of the wrestling
community on like a global scale like is
there somebody who you think most of the
communities like yeah this is what you
can do with wrestling and after
wrestling
it's a great question
um
yeah I don't know I don't know I mean I
don't
I mean it's obviously like you have like
a Jim Jordan who is you know really high
up in the uh as soon as he Congress or
Senate I'm blaming right now I don't
remember
um
yeah so that would be one I know people
kind of think about a lot
um and it is a handful of other
successful business people but I don't
think anyone really has that
conversation about like who's I mean I
think people just think like in
wrestling like kill Sanderson like you
know he's coached nine national
championship teams now uh people think a
lot about him and probably like the guys
who have done it well on MMA like uh
Henry sahudo or Daniel Cormier
um those type of people right there's
been a lot of Wrestling champions and
mixed martial arts but who's the best
MMA journalist
Chuck Mendenhall of course
who would you say for real chuckman at
all really help me write my book yeah no
he's great
um
obviously Ariel does a great job uh I
think there's there's quite I think
Ariel's been uh disrupted
why is that have you not seen Andrew
Schultz is out there saying he's the
greatest MMA journalist of all time
Andrew Schulz says that where did he say
this I didn't see this he like making
these videos every time there's a big
UFC and he like comments about
whatever's going on he like he said
something and people all started
freaking out and saying like you're not
an MMA journalist he's just some of the
greatest one of all time oh that's
hilarious and so now he him and uh
helwani are you know in competition with
each other oh nice I was like him so uh
so I'll let him have it well how Wanda
uh is actually pretty interesting
because he's been able to do this for a
long time now he's been here for a long
time since the very beginning right like
yeah really really early years and he
also what he was uh with one of the
organizations loses ESPN now ESPN I
believe now he's off kind of just
independent a little bit I mean like
yeah talk about winning right yeah
absolutely basically was able to get
himself in a position where like he was
the brand someone can do it on their own
terms is is huge yeah it's kind of like
ask her in Wrestling Academy I'm trying
I'm trying to do as much as I can on my
own I mean I always think about you know
from a monetary perspective obviously
there's people who are wealthier than me
but one of the things I really love
about my life is that like I don't have
a boss like no one tells me what to do I
don't fear anyone's approval or whatever
uh and that's a really good position to
be in I think there's even a lot of like
really successful people who are like
worried about what their boss is gonna
say or they know they can't do or can't
do it and I'm in a position where I'm
like if I want to do that I'm going to
do it and if I don't want to do it I'm
not gonna do it and that's it the only
life that I'm like man I think I really
struggle to be happy like there's a lot
of [ __ ] I probably could do and be like
okay uh and like find happiness in it
but the like nine to five suit and tie
go sit in a cubicle
if that's your thing more power to you
but like that's the one I think I I have
a tough time yeah the other one I mean
now is uh and obviously you know I'm
here in Miami so I'm traveling a little
bit but the other was like when you
start having a family
um this is actually I I hadn't traveled
for like four months without my family
which was pretty wild because usually it
has it's a little more than that but
someone who had to travel a ton with
their family like I think that would be
really hard like
and I think I'd be somewhere you'd like
really question your life of like yeah
I'm making a lot of money I'm having a
ton of success but I barely ever get to
see my family yeah like is that really
what I'm worth it is it worth it yeah
exactly where uh where can we send
people to get the book uh so it's
available Barnes Noble Amazon
um funky my defiant path through the
wild wild world of Combat Sports the the
title is a tongue twister so I struggled
with it I know I messed it up twice when
I was recording the audiobook the
audiobook was I don't know if you've
done audiobook yet maybe you will
someone I just wanna I just want to
share everyone who are who's watching
that that was Ben when I when I was
going through the book I saw this and I
was like bro what I never knew this what
uh what you look like in college that
one was in high school I have I'm in
high school uh yep I have a similar my
junior of college I think was my other
time where it was like at the uh Apex
afro
um
yeah uh so I did the audiobook that was
like oh man that was hard that was hard
well because you got to read and so okay
you and I are speaking on a podcast
right yeah if I were to mess up a word I
would just keep going yeah right yeah
where if I gotta read every single word
and get a word for word yeah and I miss
like an and or a the or I gotta start
over some the whole thing well the
decision or wherever you know do you
have someone there being like oh you
messed up go back
um no most of the time you know you knew
there was only a couple times where they
said like hey you missed that you know
but then so uh being the hard part for
me is I had to slow down significantly
from my talk you know so like I you know
if I'm talking like this I would have to
really like and this blah blah blah you
know what I'm saying it was like it was
just yeah so it was a challenge the only
thing I ask people if you're gonna do
audiobook not to do
I I love learning from them but Ray
dalio for changing World Order
he reads the first like or two and then
he rug pulls you I love it he says I'm
too busy
I'm too busy so uh-so's gonna take over
what
yeah like either either don't record any
of it or record the whole thing but the
like
you buy the audiobook you start
listening and then he literally like a
chapter and it's like all right this
other guy's gonna read I loved it I'm
like yeah it probably is too busy of
course he's too busy but I was like dude
what no did he did he do the first
chapter was it was it only the intro
because no I think you're right because
I think I think I was thinking it would
have made more sense if he would have
just done like the intro yeah yeah and
not the first chapter also but it felt
like he was going to do the audiobook
and then decided not to do it at some
point well I don't blame him because I
did one it was freaking hard yeah and
his book's very long he's very long and
then he's a couple too because I think I
think once I listen to the first one I
think I listened to like a couple more
and I think he did something similar uh
where he read the if I remember he did
the first part then not the rest yeah no
I love that that was a really good book
too he's out here just tricking people
yes all right where can we send people
to find you on the internet uh I really
just use Twitter I obviously have my
Instagram but I don't really love
Instagram uh I really love Twitter so
it's been asking all right I appreciate
it we'll definitely do it again future
all right thanks man